morning Millennials welcome back to the
morning toast happy hump day it is
Wednesday Theo is here we have deer
toasters it is the most Wednesday
Wednesday that ever Wednesday is it
though because we took off Monday so
it's a Tuesday he Wednesday I woke up
today thinking it was Thursday yeah so
we got a problem yeah I'm back to that
part of quarantine where like I don't
know what day it is I don't really care
as long as it's not Monday yeah I don't
I don't know I don't care Theo is here
to celebrate hump day of course he is
because he is our hump mascot
he's the country before we dive in must
issue a correction from yesterday's show
I was hoaxed you guys she was hope I
hate when people do this so as I shared
that BBC News accidentally published a
July 11th article sank d'Alene Maxwell
was moved to ICU for coronavirus
complications that was a hoax like
someone on 4chan started it and I didn't
I don't think they started it to be a
hoax I think they mean like it was like
a funny meme like this is what's coming
guys oh well people took it at face
value you know I feel like Americans
already have a hard time trusting the
media and these hoaxes just don't help
yeah and I fell prey to the hoax I'm
sorry for spreading this information
it's not the first time that has
happened here and it most certainly
won't be the last but I must issue a
correction it was not real and that's
really upsetting because the conspiracy
theory that I have in my brain like
something like that would happen yeah
but you know what it's actually positive
news because it allows us to believe in
the system a little bit more not just
believe that like it's not gonna happen
for us right so I'm going back to my
faith in the system that justice per
tential II potentially protected be
served potentially is when something is
pertinent and potential and it perhaps
could happen so sorry about that you
guys my mistake um but other than that
happy Wednesday everyone hope everyone
had a fabulous day yesterday we had a
fabulous evening had a fabulous evening
celebrating Olivia's birthday you know
quarantine birthdays are kind of
depressing but something about being at
Olivia's little dinner last night was
not depressing at all because it was the
power of the press Kayla and I don't
think we would have done anything even
if Olivia we weren't in quarantine
because Olivia's a new mom and she just
wanted to be with fresh chela and we got
to be with pres chela and honestly I
think
like last night umm like cemented a new
bond in my relationship with Mikaela
like she was living for me yes she was
living for you when you left she was
living for Zack was she yeah it was
really sweet and so it was just such a
great night and now it's the road to
your birthday I know this is just so
depressing honestly because I had so
many plans for my birthday and I was
like laughing scuffing at other people
who had quarantine birthdays and I'm
like that's not gonna be me in July and
the joke is on me because Here I am I
guess like technically with all the
phases like I could have like a small
get-together but one I'm not really
interested in doing that to nobody know
what is in a city and three like it
would just be too sad I'm really an
all-or-nothing birthday kind of gal
understand I'm not like a middle middle
kind of gal so it'll just be a small
dinner at home but whatever I'm like
over it I'm 26
my favorite kind of birthdays and that's
like I don't know it'll be interesting
to see if we're still in quarantine for
my birthday I mean that's [ __ ]
depressing Jackie's birthday's in
November yes you should know I mean it
might be second wave season by then who
knows who the hell knows not me not me I
don't thinking that one day at a time
here at the morning one day at a time
so aside from that it was a great day
lots to discuss today not as much as
yesterday there was so much to discuss
so much news yesterday um I hope
everyone headed over to our Instagram at
the morning toast and saw those fabulous
pictures of Morgan McGraw and Jordan
McGraw's new house ten million dollars
bought by daddy Phil daddy Phil yeah and
like I just I keep thinking about her
life there and I like to dream about it
for her and I'm just so excited about it
so excited about it um should we get
right into it we have a lot to cover
today we have your toaster if your
toasters which is of course our advice
segment so if you guys want to write in
you can email dear toasters at gmail.com
we always keep it anonymous and you can
really write in about anything we got
some weird ones today
um and I love Wednesdays and I loved
your toaster so much me too but before
we do that we have to get into the fast
five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast Thank You Jackie
that's beautiful morning burp at the end
there here's your daily reminder to
check out my comedy special disgraced
Queen available on Amazon iTunes Google
Play
there's really no excuse it's on all the
platforms both audio and video check it
out let me know what you think Thanks
speaking of comedy first story
Charlemagne the god inks to deal with
Comedy Central for a talk-show New York
radio superstar Charlemagne the God has
inked a deal with Comedy Central to make
his own talk show
vulture reports the news comes amid
speculation that he won't reopen
contract for 105.1 The Breakfast Club
when it ends at the end of the year
quite interest sunt back in Marja source
told page six there are a lot of
potential deals in the air and he just
wants to keep his options open and think
strategically yeah the weekly half-hour
talk show could air as soon as November
I mean I don't know why you can't do a
weekly talk show for a half-hour and
then also a radio show but I'm assuming
it has something to do with contractual
obligations and is is The Breakfast Club
in New York show where it's like a
national show it's nationally syndicated
serious ER which I heard I heard radio
um this is so crazy because I feel like
so many people like this would be like
Howard Stern like he's a part of
people's day's routines he's been on The
Breakfast Club forever but I do think
like Charlemagne is on to bigger and
better things yet the way they're
positioning this sounds kind of like a
late-night talk show and I think
Charlemagne would be fabulous at that I
hope he starts it once a week and goes
up to five nights a week if things go
well I think this is really exciting and
I absolutely love Charlemagne you know I
love to hear some good news I'm not in
love with the Comedy Central selection
because that's just like a random
Network and I honestly don't know if
many people really watch Comedy Central
anymore it's not really what it used to
be but I think you ever watch Comedy
Central literally never in my life
actually I watched some of the roasts
which are pretty fabulous
that's Amy Schumer show Oh inside Amy
Schumer yeah so good I just feel like
what's on Comedy Central now like what
do people go there to watch Trevor Noah
yank you I thought maybe so whoa
actually this oh yeah The Trevor Noah
vibe actually is perfect for Charlemagne
I could see them both like doing funny
talk shows but it just seems random I
don't think it's random he's a comedy
guy Comedy Central's clearly you know
making moves and I think it's it's a
good it's a good place to be where did
you first learn about Charlie in the god
I'm good
yes we - yeah of course I was that like
for him his launching pad her just yeah
I think probably for us yeah that was a
great touch a good show they need to
bring that back yeah girl code and guy
code though and honestly
girl code really launched a lot of stars
Carly Aquilino Nicole Byer new buyer
Nessa mm-hmm fabulous um some other
exciting news bethany frankel just
launched her self-made mobile podcast
called just be um Bethenny Frankel
posted her Instagram yesterday that she
is starting a podcast called just be she
is teamed with endeavor content for the
podcast it's devoted to being a
self-made mobile in business lifestyle
and beyond I want to be what she posted
yesterday because it honestly sounded
really interesting like a good ass
podcast I love this move for bet I love
this move she said this just in the B is
back and I'm going to mention it all on
my new podcast coming soon
just be with Bethenny Frankel will be an
unfiltered polarizing conversation with
self-made moguls who have started from
the bottom and are here these fearless
game changers will engage in interesting
conversations about the unconventional
journey to success guests include
entrepreneur Mark Cuban newly named seat
Netflix CMO Bose OMA Saint John
entrepreneur Gary Vaynerchuk etc we are
in the moat we are in a moment in time
where people are afraid to express
themselves and only present filtered or
watered-down versions of the truth if
this is what you're interested in then
this podcast is not for you I'm gonna
hold her to that because yeah it's so
much easier said than done Bethenny I'm
sure I'll get in some trouble
I may say something inappropriate or
politically incorrect but I am always
open to being educated good luck with
that Bethenny that's fine be an honest
place for a real conversation if you
can't handle the truth
you can't handle this podcast you can't
handle the truth I mean I love this I
feel like everyone with a podcast sets
out with this mentality like unfiltered
say whatever you want and then you get
like literally so much backlash that
like it cripples your life and your
self-worth and you just do it and say
what other people want you to say
because it's easier thing to do um but I
implore you to do that Bethenny good
luck I'm just a little disappointed and
just be I'm not like living for the name
and it really should have been mentioned
at all I think okay men
at all obviously it's an amazing name
for a house-wide podcast but that's not
what this is and I think she's trying to
move away from that which I get yes but
honestly it would have been just an
iconic nod to her past while walking
into her future but then it's gonna be
the thing that's always mentioned with
her and it's it's going I understand why
why it's not it but what's always made
her so fabulous is her ability to be on
shark tank and the Real Housewives like
it's this the chin Rattus fears that she
strategies no longer on the Real
Housewives no but that's what everyone
knows her I just would have appreciated
a little bit more of a creative if she
were a housewife who was done on
Housewives and was gonna start a podcast
like because that's what you do next she
could call it mention at all but like
this is something completely different
no but what she just described is people
mentioning at all like it's really a
perfect name no it's like a great
tagline maybe they'll have like a
segment or something but I think she
needed like a more elevated business
name if this is really gonna if like
Mark Cuban's going on and this is really
gonna be the business podcast to the
star I just think it was a missed iconic
opportunity that's all she obviously she
saw the opportunity and she she went
around it because she missed it in her
caption miss do you guys know just be
like it's just me just be well I will I
will be listening just to make sure
she's you know got her levels right and
really being unfiltered you know no I
think this is a great idea I think she's
a born podcaster I agree um
as per usual we always welcome everyone
into the space with open arms yes please
Bethenny come on so excited to have you
especially when I feel as though it's a
person who was made for this medium yeah
and it just feels good to like I feel
like when you're a podcaster when a huge
like stars or people you really respect
join the podcasting world it just kind
of like reinforces like that what we're
doing is cool you know yes definitely
defies the space for sure and makes it
legit yeah
but we were making it legit hey I'm
really excited about this I think this
is a great next venture for her did that
show ever come out she no not yes at HBO
man I think so she had inked a new show
with Mark Burnett it was like a shark
tank type it was like Project Runway for
entrepreneurs Yeah right
I don't think it ever came out no I
don't you ever subscribed to HBO
everything's on
um did I ever subscribe to HBO max
depends if I went to watch something and
it was only available yeah I think I did
I think I have it yeah I don't think
I've watched anything yet I'm ready for
Gary Janney show me too I heard that the
launch was successful but I don't know
anyone who's really like using it or
talking about any of the original
programming but according to you know
statistics they say that it was a great
launch here's what happened it the HBO
now app and you know what they're so
messy over there and they're clearly
cleaning up but yeah the I used to have
HBO go and HBO now I never know which
one did the thing I needed to do what I
always try both but I always had
literally same HBO now turned into HBO
max so it's already on my TV
Oh things like it I might have to make a
login of some so there's HBO on demand
HBO go HBO now HBO max like it's so
confusing now I think is gone okay
goodbye
good riddance goodbye Kyle like it never
did anything in the first place agreed
there's an HBO app you get a period I
believe I believe that I have it makes
you a question mark
you know HBO exclamation point yeah
nobody it's clear that they're getting
their [ __ ] together and I will be
watching HBO max when the programming
I've been waiting for it comes out which
is the Gary Jannetty show which is a
cartoon based off of Prince George which
is just gonna be so fabulous even though
so happy the trailer they released for
it which was just like a minute was so
entertaining that's the type of content
that stupid on Genuity we need at these
big networks like some genius who said
let's work with Gary Jannetty on a
cartoon about Prince George that is the
type of thinking we need in this in this
current climate
I agree I totally agree and then Bethany
show but she's not really gonna be on
camera that much so we'll see how I feel
about it
but anyways another podcast to add to
our repertoire the repertoire I am a
little offended shouldn't go with toast
news network but it was such a tough
call at the end and you know I trust
Bethany she had to do what was right for
her business and I totally respect and
understand that but just know you always
have a home here at toast news network
Bethenny Frankel I heard she was just
like fielding offers left and right and
TNN came really close allegedly but it
just it wasn't it didn't pan out
we are also 100% kidding for those who
maybe not understanding our words were
ready to email
oh that was funny love that okay oh I'm
sorry
um I have something to say to you yeah
is that okay
do you think now's the time yeah okay
I've been wanting to get this off my
chest for a while and I've always said
that I'm gonna be open and honest and
transparent on this show and today is no
different so having said that I have an
announcement okay
today's episode is brought to you by
honey we all shop online and we've all
seen that promo code field taunt us at
checkout but thanks to honey manually
searching for coupon codes is a thing of
the past
honey is the free browser extension that
helps find promo codes for you and
automatically applies them to your cart
a checkout how it works is so simple
it's a browser extension I've had it
long before they sponsor this show a lot
of toasters told me about it and it's
literally the most life-changing easy
thing you know I have to click like they
do it for you um so basically you're
shopping at one of your favorite website
um I can use it on revolve Ulta like
every website you've ever imagined when
you check out the honey button drops
down and all you have to do is click
apply
coupons you wait a few seconds as honey
scans its database of all the working
coupons for that site and then you just
watch the price drop so easy so simple
I've seen so much money on honey and
literally from makeup clothing
athleisure yes I have biker shorts it's
just the most fabulous application and
it's so easy to install and studied easy
to use and like it's literally free
money there's there's literally no
negative so if you're not using it what
is you doing there's no downside I use
honey for every single site that I shop
some sites have just like fabulous honey
integration and it's just a wonderful
place to eat honey is everything of the
sort and if you're shopping online
you're not shopping with honey like you
are wasting money you are nothing of the
sort
honey has found it's over 17 million
members over two billion dollars in
savings and they support over 30,000
stores online so some of the places you
can use it forever 21 Walmart doordash
Lululemon like all the places if you
don't already have honey you can be
missing out on free money it's free to
install and installs in just a few
seconds by getting it you'll be doing
yourself a solid and supporting our
podcast if you go to get honey for free
join honey dot-com slash toast
so if
want to support our podcasts and doing
yourself a solid go to join honey
dot-com slash toasts join honey dot-com
slash toasts to get honey for free you
have to go to join Jo i-n honey dot-com
slash toast that's join honey dot-com
slash toast thank you honey
I can't wait to join honeycomb slash
toast okay next story the kids are not
alright there is some major tick tock
drama brewing and we're gonna try and
get to the bottom of it the kids are not
alright you see that's the name of
today's episode they are so unwell I've
been seeing some of the crazies and I
guess I guess for me it feels so crazy
but it's kind of the equivalent like for
for teenagers who like look up to these
kids and like these are their biggest
celebrities it's very similar to the
hills so like I'm really shocked that
these kids are getting paparazzi but
it's actually not that shocking you know
it's just like a different it's really a
different generation yeah it's a
different generation they have different
like ways of spilling the tea and here's
the team tic TOCs Nessa Barrett
denounces slut-shaming I made Charlie
D'Amelio and chase Hudson drama drama
has erupt in among some of tick-tocks
biggest names according to 17 fans began
I think this is the first time we've
ever reported on something from 17 yeah
according to 17 fans began realizing on
Monday that several stars from the
platform had unfollowed each other on
Instagram that included included Josh
Richards Bryce Hall and more former and
current White House members unfollowing
Chase Hudson aka lil honey then Hudson's
ex-girlfriend Charlie to Milly oh you
guys know her waded into the drama
seemingly lashing out at him in a tweet
that read I hope she was worth it it's
smiling dead this is so like music video
do you know what I mean like it's just
so also like so contrived in like so
high school the tweet has been deleted
well that makes sense considering these
are high schoolers yeah but a tick tock
fan account the tick tock room captured
a screenshot according to the account
D'Amelio also deleted all of her
Instagram pictures with lil hoodie
Hudson aka little hoodie in a since
deleted tweet claiming that all of this
drama is going on because I kiss Nessa
when we were both single as fans know
Nessa is Richards's ex-girlfriend and
her
Cena's rumoured to have sent her an
inappropriate photo while dating Emilio
who and she denied then D'Amelio replied
quote then you shouldn't have come to my
house after without telling me
then Hudson decided to air out more
drama for the tic-tock community in a
lengthy tweet he later deleted prompting
a scathing response from Charlie she
said stop deflecting your actions onto
others because you can't take
responsibility chase want me to talk to
want me to talk about how you treated me
throughout our relationship or you just
want to continue to play the victim
Shero guys this is honestly like I never
say this but like this is too much like
I'm overwhelmed with information I'm
pretty sure I follow what's going on but
in case you can't follow all you really
need to know what's that these young
group of kids like some of them are
dating some of them are hooking up and
there's some drama maybe they're just
like a kiss that sent the world a flame
and this girl Nessa is like not really
she's not a part of the high pass and
she's not really as popular as the other
girls like I'm surprised she even got to
hang out with this crew and to be honest
the only stuff I've really heard about
her is very negative so I'm like shocked
that she's even included in this
conversation and to me like this is a
lesson for a young burgeoning charlie'd
Emilio like you hang out with trash like
you start to smell like I this is like
Charlie D'Amelio was at the Super Bowl
she met JLo she's one of the biggest
stars in the world right now like what
is she doing getting involved with
little Hootie like he is the definition
of nothing of the sort and look what
happened like you'd lie with dogs you
get fleas the hype house is nothing of
this or nothing of the sort it's so
trashing so a house I'm team Jame Leo
and Addison who live at home with their
parents like normal 17 year olds like
I'm team stability yeah I'm house
stability I agree so this is just like I
don't really feel the need to get into
like the inner workings like he kissed
Nessa to be honest like Charley D'Amelio
is better than this and she shouldn't
really have ever been with Chase just on
a looks level but like she can't help
how she sounds on a looks level it's not
really equal and just on a personality
star level it's not equal either so this
is a lesson like you are who you hang
out with you are who you associate with
and Charley's now being like dragged to
this like trashy tacky ass drama
we're like the hype house kids are
literally calling paparazzi to the
garage and like filming fake fights it's
so fake it's so stupid I can't like
Charlie so much better than this like
justice for Charlie
so little honey tweeted this yes
statement statement like spilling and
the Tia about everyone else about how
Anthony got with Sophia a week after we
broke up on tour how Jaden actively
shower Jaden accidently tried to hook up
with Dixie at her house on the 4th of
July in front of me while she was dating
Griffin so I think that Dixie is still
dating Griffin and I kind of shipped
like I'm really actually slowly turning
into a Dixie D'Amelio Stan after just
thinking she was like dead weight in the
D'Amelio family she's not that songs
good slap it's good cuz honestly
sometimes I don't want to be happy but
do you know while jaden was actively
trying to hook up with Dixie on the 4th
of July even though she was dating
Griffin Griffin cheated on Dixie with
Taylor's ex Kaylin and Bryce's ex l oh
man this is so [ __ ] messy you guys
like I'm I'm not even gonna spend my
time trying to trace like who's who
but it is my understanding that like I
don't know I can't tell if this is like
a genius marketing move because
everyone's talking about this like
literally old young everyone is talking
about this people who don't get it
people who get it and it's really I
imagine for like the 16 year old to like
these are their favorite celebrities
this is such an exciting time this is
like the best episode of the hills ever
but for an adult like I'm seeing I'm
seeing and she's like dad why are these
people cheating on each other totally
this is what happens when like really
young kids from the middle of nowhere
just like rise to fame you know they
like lose all sense of self so sad also
this this is really sad like crazy he
said the only person who has a right to
be upset with me is Charlie and I'm
sorry I hurt her we broke up and I
messed up by kissing Nessa I'm not sorry
- Josh we are not boys and we haven't
been boys since he lied to Charlie
saying I and I had an STD six months ago
trying to get her to stop seeing me I'm
not going to let these hypocrites trimer
in my life without their lives being out
on the Internet
- you know and then money you brought
everyone down with that so what's the
point
like three jobs to live forever so don't
if you're gonna go out and say something
crazy like you need to stand by it
because screenshots exist forever
otherwise it makes me think that it's a
lie oh yeah yeah totally so this is so
crazy y'all like I truly can't even
comprehend really all the intricacies
but all you need to know is that it's
crazy
and justice for Charlie in my opinion
yeah and the ones who like we love
Charlie
Addison they're they're alright they're
good girls actually feel like they are
like decent role models I agree I think
that they're not the worst people for
you know young girls to look up to
they're they don't get Botox they're
like normal looking girls and they're
like nice and they live in there and
having fun and dancing yeah I can't I
feel like we really need to separate
like the trash in terms of the the
tic-tock crew we need to take out the
trash yeah I agree
so that's what's up with the kids yeah
in case you need something to talk to
your like younger sibling or daughter
about at dinner tonight tell them about
this white house drama yeah tell them
that you Sam with Charlie yeah and that
you know when you hang out with trash
you start to smell yeah it's honestly an
important lesson for the children yeah I
know who you associate with and you lay
with dogs yes please scratch scratch oh
okay next story really um tough news for
Teddy Mellencamp and her husband who are
pushing forward after their daughters
diagnosis so um Kenny Mellencamp's
husband opened up about their four
month-old daughter doves upcoming
neurosurgery Teddy had shared with her
social media that her daughter has her
doctors caught her early diagnosis of
LAM Boyd craniosynostosis
craniosynostosis and occurs when one of
the lamboy sutures of the back of the
head fuses before birth so they're
preparing for surgery and Edwin wrote on
his sorry Instagram that life is always
going to punch you in the face Teddy
Mellencamp and I got some difficult news
about our sweet baby girl Dov was
diagnosed with lamboy craniosynostosis
and has to undergo neurosurgery at the
end of the month it happens every time
right when you're about to experience
blessing and fulfillment in life
something comes along that threatens to
bring you down so true
he said the challenges can shape us into
who were meant to be or they can scare
us into going back to who we used to be
also so true he said he feels the most
tested when the people he loves are
experiencing hardship
however he's feeling stronger in his
face following doves Diagnostics
explaining that more than ever God has a
plan I'm going to get through this and
stay the course push forward with
unwavering faith and focus on the things
you can control
don't quit it's actually a beautifully
written statement hmm and this you know
like brain surgery is so scary and it's
so real and especially for a young child
and in this I was having this
conversation with Olivia last night
because you know Teddy's a new mom
Olivia's a new mom and it's like you see
things on social media and it really
makes you question like am i doing like
this person's life is so perfect they're
questioning everything that you're doing
you yeah and it's like it looks like
everything's so great and you know we
say this all the time and it's so true
it's like you really just never know
what's going on in someone's life and
you really should never judge them
because you just have no [ __ ] idea um
and I think it's very brave that they're
you know sharing because this is very
personal and obviously no one would
fault her if she wanted to keep this
private but I just loved Teddy
Mellencamp and I love her family and I
love how like they're so faith-based you
know yeah everything they do is like
rooted in their faith in God it's really
inspiring it is really inspiring and
we'll all be thinking of her and praying
for her yeah baby and and I love the
name dove I love the name dove is
beautiful be also very biblical almost
spiritual yes for the final story Mary
Kay Letourneau has died of cancer at the
age of 58 the ex teacher was a
controversial figure who gained national
notoriety notoriety after being jailed
for sexually abusing her student than
later marrying him Mary Kay Letourneau
the controversial Washington middle
school teacher has died of stage four
cancer people confirmed was she in jail
at the time of her death no she's been
out for a little while I would think so
okay um this is a tough story to report
on because I respect the dead I do but I
don't respect child predators and this
leaves me at a crossroads yeah because
honestly I wish her well bye yeah bye
she's like this she's like the go-to
person yes she's an adjective now yes
you have Mary Kay Letourneau like when
there is a scandal involving usually a
female teacher but a teacher in general
and a student that's which is like
such an abuse of power and it's honestly
so apparently disgusting she is was
really like the first one and so now she
becomes like she's the face of child
predator ISM yeah she is so I guess
that's her legacy it's just so weird
when people like people like this die do
you know what I mean it's like what do
you say yeah I've nothing takes reflect
on her life and her legacy and that is
it just being like a disguise who also
married her student right just crazy no
it's crazy it's just I buy okay stories
and it will be fast what they were
pretty fast
they were pretty fast we always we are
always pretty fast here at the morning
dose and Wednesday means dear toaster so
we were gonna jump into our advice
Eggman twitch is truly my favorite part
of the week again email us to your
toasters at gmail.com let's dive in dear
Jackie and Claudia I caught my boyfriend
of two and a half years sexting an 18
year old I'm 25 he's 26 let me start by
saying that before all this went down he
was literally the perfect boyfriend he
treated me so well and he really loved
me
everyone was shook when they found out
what he was hiding here's where it gets
weird about six weeks ago I received a
DM from a family friend of my boyfriends
telling me that my boyfriend had been
sexting with her eighteen year old
daughter she sent screenshots I knew
immediately it was true I confronted him
about it and he admitted to it but
that's not all he also admitted to
meeting other random girls on online
chat rooms where he would sext and
exchange nudes and that he's been doing
this throughout our entire relationship
apparently he's been doing this since he
was a teenager it's like a weird secret
sexting fetish that I never knew about
and then he goes on to tell me that the
same thing ended his last serious
relationship he claims to have never
physically cheated on me and I believed
him but the girls age is really
concerning to me I know that she's 18 so
it's technically legal but it's like
really [ __ ] weird right it's weird
it's been six weeks since we six weeks
and we haven't seen each other but we
left things more on a break than a
breakup what do you think is sexting
cheating would it be different if she
wasn't [ __ ] 18 years old I sometimes
think that if she were older I wouldn't
be as mad do I stay or do I go
Oh get the [ __ ] out of his face I mean
all of the elements of this are
concerning sexting is 100% cheating
there's there's a difference between
like flirty rapport that could be
concerning and just like blame sexting
like I want to put my penis in your
vagina like that it's totally cheating
there's no doubt in my mind
and yes the age is concerning I
understand that it is like technically
legal but it's still [ __ ] weird
and beyond weird also so he has this
addiction to sexting so it's like he
can't help it and it's just who he is so
what he's gonna be doing this for the
rest of his life he's gonna be 50 years
old sexting 18 year olds on the internet
he's going to get himself on a TV show
Nightline like you do not want to be
associated with this person he needs to
correct himself had to predator like
just because you like doing something
and you're addicted to it doesn't mean
that you can't stop doing it or that you
shouldn't stop doing it like he needs to
him at some point in his life if he
cares enough about your relationship now
will be the time where he like realizes
the error of his ways and that's on you
to forgive him and see if you can move
past it but like if he's going with this
bull [ __ ] it's like I need it to live oh
god what also the fact that it was
covered up so well because you said like
the relationship was perfect before
means like he's a very good liar and you
just don't want to be with someone who
is has so much experience and is so good
at covering things up and hiding parts
of their lives because that's not what a
true relationship is built on so I'm
really sorry but this break is is must
be a breakup this he's yeah no but
sometimes like obviously to me I'm like
this is so obvious like get the [ __ ] out
of there but when you're so in it
sometimes you can't see out of it your
own situation and the person that you're
talking to is like normalizing it and
being like look I know that it's weird
okay
trust me I'm there yes well you know
what like this is who I am and didn't
know they kind of be like trying to say
facing trying to coax you into bring
that bringing you into their bucket of
weird with them and we're here to tell
you that no get out of the bucket yes
it's weird and get out of the bucket
it's really [ __ ] weird thank you for
writing in I hope I hope you got some
clarity from that I feel like that was
actually good advice yeah um next up hi
Jackie and Claudia first I want to say I
loved it the special it was truly
everything and more thank you guys my
comedy specials available on iTunes
Apple TV and so many other platforms
it's called disgrace Queen I hope you
enjoy it I just need advice on what to
do my cousin hooked up with my
friend's boyfriend I'm super close with
my cousin and our family dynamic is
definitely ride-or-die I don't know if I
should tell my friend or not my friend
is like a sister to me and was there for
me when my grandpa died and has always
had my back I don't want to throw my
cousin under the bus but I feel like my
friend deserves to know thanks in
advance from a stressed out toaster I
mean that's horrible especially you're
talking to two girls who are like family
over everything and part of me like
wants to tell you just to stay out of it
but like having those types of secrets
like those types of those those are the
things that like eat you up inside you
know yeah so I think I have a plan okay
so you can't rat on your cousin you just
can't be the snitch but your best friend
does need to know if her man and also
what sort of relationship is this like
are they gonna get engaged soon do you
think they'll get married like she needs
to know you need to catch him in the act
if he's a cheater he'll cheat again and
so you need to find the next person or
the person before that he cheated with
and tell your friend about that person
not about the cousin or you can go
directly to the source until the
boyfriend I know and I'm gonna tell but
I'm gonna give you the opportunity to do
it and just hope he doesn't worst like
snitching and well the boyfriend is then
gonna tell her oh I hooked up with
so-and-so's cousin and then she's gonna
say wait why didn't you tell me that it
was your cousin and then the cousins
gonna be like wait why'd you get in the
middle here so you have to find someone
else to pin it on you know what sorry I
changed my mind I've such a better piece
of it no tell they're not Jersey Shore
right then write a letter
tears yam when you went to bed Ron put
his head between a cocktail waitresses
breast it's perfect yeah anyway I walked
so you could run so it don't work out
really well just like it did in the
Jersey Shore it did work out well cuz
you want but you know what this is where
like cheating gets dicey because some
girls like don't want to know now it was
like Sam it's like everything that
letter was true but like she was more
fixated on who wrote it than what was
actually detailed in the letter where
it's like your boyfriend just cheat on
you she'd be mad of him instead of
trying to figure out what you girl on
the house like tried to help you so you
know I feel like reporting incidents of
infidelity is a is a fruitless act like
it's just it's a thankless job is it
somehow becomes your fault when you're
just trying to do the right thing and
toe the line between being a good friend
and a good cousin and a good
humanitarian and being able to sleep
with yourself at night it is a thankless
[ __ ] job yeah you're really just
trying me you got him young
terian yeah and just do what's right and
people make it so difficult for you and
I feel free to girlfriend so again I
don't know where we landed here um my
advice is she tried to find someone else
to pin it on you might have to wait a
little bit um but if he is a cheater
maybe because maybe like if the cousin
was just the one time and this is a
mistake and he's not gonna do it again
maybe she doesn't need to know but if
he's a cheater she needs to know and so
you can find another instance to share
with her well I have another I have
another question the cousin did she know
that this guy wasn't single like did she
know that this was her cousin's best
friend's boyfriend I'm gonna say she
didn't make it clear but I'm gonna say
yes because she hosts with her cousin
her cousins close with the best friend
and so people have a way of knowing each
other now okay I guess so then the girl
the cousin just being up front with the
friend is not an option right no because
she's I don't think she's interested in
that she and the cousin clearly she's
like this is not my relationship I don't
want to say get me out of here for sure
okay well they get that too I hope we've
given you something to think about
mm-hmm next up final one sorry I can't
speak hi Jackie and Claudia love you
gals thanks for keeping me entertained
during quarantine anyways I'd love your
input on this situation I have a best
friend who I love so much but when we go
out to drink specifically travel and go
on group vacations she turns into the
Exorcist I've known her since we were
kids and we relatively have the same
large friend group that's been together
since we were teens
that's not so fun so we're constantly
doing activities and groups now we're in
our 20s and 90% of the time when she's
drinking a lot she takes a turn and
[ __ ] loses her mind and embarrasses
herself and then never wants to talk
about it again when someone brings it up
our friends now think this is a normal
trait of hers and we all talk about it
separately when I tell you she loses her
mind she would just start yelling and
trying to pick a fight with anyone
inside and looks nuts for reference she
turns into Kelly Bensimon when she was
on scary Island and Real Housewives of
New York honestly it's very entertaining
but I feel bad and I don't know how to
address it I've tried talking to her
before telling her not to drink as much
but that didn't work anyways love you
gals you're so skinny smart and
beautiful
xoxo a girl he needs to give her friend
an exorcism oh this is why I don't have
friends y'all like it's just not worth
the burden well clearly you're a
fabulous friend if you're saying we're a
skinny smart and beautiful um so you're
not in the wrong clearly clearly you're
obviously
really good head on your shoulders yes
you see me for the beautiful woman that
I am and you obviously no matter what
advice we give you like you're gonna do
the right thing and everything's gonna
work out great because you are have a
great head on your shoulders yeah um
this is really tough because it's like
clearly your friend and alcohol do not
mix well she needs to stop drinking
parry period it is not on any person to
be responsible for getting someone else
sober especially when that person isn't
asking for help isn't looking for help
doesn't think there's a problem I'm not
accepting help at this current Junction
in time um
I think unfortunately she is just going
to have to learn this the hard way and I
think the only way that maybe you could
have an impact on her is like when these
things happen if she starts to feel like
the consequences of her actions like
sometimes someone says something when
they're drunk and it's something you
would ordinarily get mad at but you
forgive it cuz they're drunk and they
didn't mean it they don't even really
have to apologize cuz we're all just
gonna move on but if she starts waking
up the next day and it's like those
issues are still there right um and she
has to start to deal with some of her at
her drunk actions in her drunk self she
might not be so cavalier about it
capricious about drinking the way that
she does right and it's clear that she
has no self-awareness so I feel like
it's on you guys to make her aware of
herself and to be honest I feel like
like you said some people need to learn
the hard way and if she wakes up
thinking that's that nothing's wrong
like make her think that's like stop
inviting her like like make them like
tangible consequences for her actions
and maybe that'll open her up to be like
wow I'm annoying like people don't like
to hang out with me when I'm drunk like
yeah I need to change something the fact
that like she goes on these tirades and
doesn't wake up with app it like I just
personally can't relate can't relate no
sort of human level the only thing that
can really stop and make you think about
like your drinking habits is that pig
and the way you feel the next day and
like later I would do anything not to
feel this way or to take back what I
said and if you don't have that then of
course you're never gonna stop like so
it's up to you to place that pit in her
stomach I know but then you know at the
end of the day like this is where I
always land with our deer toasters it's
like you know you're in your late 20s
you're independent
like other people's problems like
sometimes it's just not your [ __ ]
problem she's making it her prime right
you have to stop inviting her I think
that's the solution that is the solution
to just be like last time on the trip
like you said to Jenny
XY and Z and we just can't have that
sort of energy when we're all drinking
and moral trying to have a good time and
right just come up with like a list of
things that she's done and I think
she'll start to take it seriously but
when there aren't consequences for your
actions how are you even supposed to
know that you messed up or that you're
doing something wrong and if she's
getting as drunk as you say she is she
probably doesn't even remember yeah so
it's on you to paint a picture for her
she probably thinks like we're all cool
with it like everyone's getting drunk
we're all just forget in the next voice
being as crazy as me yeah I just like I
can't what it must be like to like drink
be insane and not have a Pitt about it
in the morning that is a level of
insanity I cannot even relate to I I
can't relate no eye witness Lee like I
jealous you know I live to be that
careful i noxious I'm not jealous
because now I know like because of that
pit that I have in that self-awareness
like my friends aren't writing into a
podcast asking how do we get me to stop
drinking you know like this girl's
desperate like she like she needs help
and I just think you really need to
start like making it more obvious that
you're all annoyed with her that she's
doing things that are unacceptable and
that there should be consequence and
then you're also hurt by her actions
because what kind of friend would want
to hurt another friend like it seems
like during the regular daytime sobriety
she's just gone French and she's she
knows what's up so I think trying to
talk to that person and trying to make
that person understand the like what
this person did could be helpful agreed
I hope that was helpful for you and
thank you to everyone who wrote in too
dear toasters it is my favorite part of
the week so you can email us again the
email is dear toasters at gmail.com we
always keep it anonymous
don't need to worry about that you can
change names if you want but um yeah
write us in and we'll hopefully talk
about it on Aaron hopefully give some
wise words of wisdom
hopefully wise words of wisdom that's
our show anything else you want to talk
about before we bazooms uh no I've been
catching up on Real Housewives of
Potomac but we've been doing housewives
even up for patreon we did one episode
last month we're doing another on this
month of just like housewives history
and so I'm gonna share all my thoughts
when we get to the Potomac segment
yeah so again our patreon is patreon.com
slash a morning toast for $7.99 a month
you get five extra episodes from Jackie
and I whether that's video that's audio
blogs podcasts anything you want then
you also get access to the toast after
dark Facebook group which is the most
fabulous Facebook group on planet earth
and you can also their requests episodes
that you want from us we please get a
little more personal get a little more
specific more bonding machines do like
anything so if you guys want to see
something specific from us join patreon
join the group let us know what it is
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning to us the millennium morning
show where we go live Monday through
Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on
YouTube so if you're watching us on
YouTube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up I need
to change that because we no longer go
live yeah all right let me try this
mm-hmm thank you guys so much for
listening to the morning toast the
Millennial morning show where we post
videos on our YouTube channel Monday
through Friday and sometime in the
morning sometime before noon we're also
available as a podcast anywhere podcasts
can be found such Spotify iTunes
stitcher Public Radio I have radio cast
box all the places whoever you listen to
podcasts find us the morning toast and
leave a five star view about how
beautiful stunning and smart we are we
love you guys so very much we hope you
have an amazing hump day and we will see
you tomorrow for Thursday's fabulous
show bye